stephen what's up my man how we doing
i've been hearing you a lot of times you
give
husbands the advice to not necessarily
fix the problems not necessarily try to
provide solutions for
your wives when they're um when they're
venting and
talking about what's you know going on
in their lives um especially
you know in my situation my wife she is
a very stressful job and so
um i i'm just kind of getting trying to
get an idea of like what i can do more
than just saying
you know i'm sorry that sucks because
like a lot of times i'll say it
and then she'll she'll look at me like i
am
there's more than i'm gonna say and you
know it's almost like it's patronizing
to her which i don't want to come off
sounding is patronizing that's right so
you know i just want to kind of get
your thoughts on it well dude stephen
thank you so much i appreciate your
heart
and i'm grateful for guys like you who
are
trying to do this right right just like
we just talked about the last caller
um both sides of this partnership this
marriage have a responsibility to lean
in
and to do their their
part carry their water carry their
partner's water as much as they possibly
can so good for you brother
give me an example of a classic
steven and wife interaction
that you want to get better at give me
an example sure
yeah so um my wife she works uh
night shift at the hospital and so
she'll come home
um what does she do what does she do at
the hospital she's a nurse
nurse in the emergency department so i'm
just gonna say it for everybody that
sucks
okay so go ahead that's hard it's a hard
job
yeah yeah it is and and so she you know
she'll
you know come home and and you know
she's just exhausted obviously because
i've been sleeping the whole night
she hasn't um and so you know i'll be
energized i'll be ready to go
and she'll just say you know all these
things that have that happened and
and you know i'm somebody who's very you
know solution oriented and so
you know i'll i'll provide some advice
say hey maybe you do this
next time or maybe you know maybe this
is what these people are thinking and
and so maybe try to give them the
benefit of the doubt and
i know that's the wrong thing to say
because then she
she uh she um you know you know it kind
of gives me a look like oh you know
i should i should be taking her aside so
steven what do you do for a living what
do you do for a living
i work at a uh liberty university okay
so you work at a uni
are you a professor are you just uh uh
student affairs you work in the
institution
like administration in technology okay
so you probably know this but i'm just
saying this for my own benefit
if your wife is working the midnight
shift as a nurse
her job is to keep humans alive right
exactly
to like give them stuff in blood and
needles and hearts and
body parts and stuff right absolutely
which i get queasy about
yes so i will just tell you
just between us dudes um
she's brilliant right oh yeah yeah
absolutely and she suckered you into
marrying her right
yes so she does
not need your advice
absolutely and so we live in a in a
cultural ethos you've heard the thing
like the two fish swimming one way the
two young fish and the old fish
swim the other way and the two young
fish ask like um
the old fish says hey uh you know how's
the water
and the young fish are like what's water
you know what i mean the water that we
breathe the water that we swim in we
don't breathe we breathe air
um the water that we swim in here is
that guys have value for two things
their muscles their actions the things
they are doing
and their knowledge that is where guys
get
value from right as dwight from the
office says
guys have strong arms right yeah and
they've also got
knowledge that's it and so you have to
do the hard work of disassociating from
the culture that you live in
which is that your value only comes from
your arms and your head right
you work tech all day people come to you
all day looking for solutions to
problems right
you should be my tech guy i don't know
how to turn email on brother
it's embarrassing right and so guys like
me are coming to you all day hey can you
help fix this can you solve this and
usually you
i'm telling you what you guys set up a
scam uit people got
where you have figured out all you have
to do is like oh my gosh just turn it
off and turn it back on i still don't
freaking know how any of that stuff
works but
kudos to you guys for owning the world
with just control delete and turning off
and turning back on
but here's the thing you've got to walk
away from that cultural nonsense that
you are only worth your advice
what you are worth is your presence
okay and if absolutely most guys do not
and i'm
i'm over gendering this and i'm over
stereotyping this so
go ahead and send me your cards and
letters and i'll afford them onto james
childs here
but so many guys don't even know
what that feels like to be in the
presence of somebody
because they've been trained since they
were four that they are only that
their only value is what they accomplish
and what they can cram in their heads
what knowledge they can impart to other
people
right i watch my 10 year old is always
teaching
people how to do things and it's like
dude i've been here a long time i know
how to do that right you know what i'm
saying
um and so what i want you to practice
is a couple of things one when she
starts talking
tell her i'm lo i'm practicing presents
okay and let her know that you're trying
that's a gift okay
let her know that you're trying that's a
secret word it's called vulnerability
let her know i'm gonna try to be present
here when you're talking truly
listen to you can i give you a cheesy
cheesy thing that people are going to be
rolling their eyes when they're
listening to this
they're going to be walking down the
street listening to this i'm going to
roll their eyes but i've tried it and it
works and i do it regularly you want to
hear it
i learned this from a like a very
um ethereal therapist she was brilliant
and she taught me this
when you keep when you're meeting with a
client was what she was talking about
and you keep finding yourself phasing
out right you find yourself like
getting distracted or you keep having to
lean back in to pay closer attention
she said i want you to pretend there is
a ray of light between your heart and
their heart
just connect to them that way and so in
your it sounds
cheesy and oh my gosh i'm rolling my own
eyes saying it but
kelly's in there just going oh geez
louise no one's getting to this cold
black heart of mine
um but i want you to sit down and i want
you just to pretend there is a
light that is coming from your heart
into hers okay and then i want you to
look in their eyes and just
listen i just had a hard tearful
conversation
yesterday in my home okay and man
it's so frustrating because i thought i
could solve those problems but my wife
wasn't coming to me for that she was
coming something
to me for something that's still still
foreign to me and that was
just me does that make sense yep
okay there is a power in the pause i
learned that when i worked at a law
school there's a power in the pause
just letting that weight of two people
in a room looking at each other just
be and it's something you have to
practice okay
and then i'll tell you what i do in my
house steven and it's worked wonders
after we have that pause after she comes
home and says hey
last night was super ridiculous the
doctor gave all these crazy orders
they've upped our patient load did this
and this and this and i've got to work
overtime tomorrow night
and then your first thought is what it
is you seem to tell them that they just
need to
right have you ever thought about
talking to that doctor and just getting
coffee with them until right so that's
where your head's going is that right
absolutely right yes and so let her
speak
when she starts talking say hey i'm
going to practice being present with you
i just want to listen deeply here and
she'll probably go
uh what happened to my husband and
michelle's talk
and then when she gets done i want you
to be a space
and then i want you to ask this magic
question
are you asking me for my thoughts or my
input here
or can i just be here and listen and let
her tell you
i want you to tell me what you think i
should do next
and be invited into the advice part of
that relationship is that you get what
i'm saying
absolutely i sure do and so when i say
that does that sound nuts
no not at all not at all i i suppose i
you know
whenever when i've said you know the the
you know you kind of
your standard phrase seems to be like
you know man i'm sorry you know that
really sucks and i'll
i'll say that and then she'll kind of
look at me waiting for more and so
i like the idea of saying you know i'm
just gonna sit here and listen and then
and then if if you want my advice i'd be
more than happy to give it if not then
i'll just shut up and stop talking no
no don't don't do that what you just did
was super dude passive aggressive
if you want my advice you just have to
ask for it bro like if you want to like
have everything in your life great i've
got it but
if you want to be an idiot don't do that
okay
tell her ask her are you asking me for
my advice in this situation
or do you just want to be heard okay and
preface all of this with a conversation
tonight okay this is your homework
assignment brother
i want you to sit down tonight and say
2021 i want to become a better listener
and so i'm gonna have to practice and so
when you come home from work i'm gonna
practice not giving you advice unless
you specifically ask me for it
and she will probably hug you and kiss
you harder than you've ever been kissed
in your whole
life but i want you to tell her i think
you're brilliant and i think you are
a gift to the people that you get to
serve and help every night
and probably the last thing on earth you
need is more advice from an i.t dude
if she comes to you with a laptop
problem jump in brother both
feet start control all deleting the crap
out of everything right
like turn it off and turn it on and turn
it back off and turn on dude all those
things that you
yeah you guys it's ridiculous what scam
y'all got going but
keep doing all that but start tonight
and say
what i just said i'm going to say it one
more time for everybody listening
honey it's 20 21 i want to become a
better listener this year i feel like
i'm always trying to give you advice and
i don't really hear you
so from now on i'm going to do my best
to be present and
listen to you and if you want my advice
on something
i want you to ask me for it if i want
you to invite me into
if if you want my like my two cents and
i'm telling you right now stephen the
first time this happens
you are gonna have to be biting your lip
you're gonna take a sock and shove it in
your
in your mouth because you're just gonna
be like dude just tell the doctor to
stop right whatever the thing is
you're gonna have to really fight to not
do this
but here's what's gonna happen you're
gonna keep your mouth shut and it's
gonna be so weird you're gonna be
sweating and all weird and looking at
her through the top of your eyes
and it's gonna be awkward and weird and
she's gonna think you've lost your mind
you already work at liberty so let's be
honest but she's going to think you've
really lost your mind
and then there's going to be just a
pause and then you're going to say these
magic words can we just hug
and then you're going to hug and then
nothing and then nothing
then the next time she's going to come
home she's going to say
you know what happened at work today and
you're going to say i'm going to
practice being present you're going to
look at her and she's going to start
talking and you're just going to look at
her
and you're going to pretend that your
hearts are connected i know it sounds
cheesy everybody's go with me on it
you're gonna pretend your hearts are
connected
and then when it's over you're gonna hug
and then one out of five times she's
gonna say what do you think i should
tell that guy and then you're gonna be
like
yes this is my moment just control all
delete or whatever it is you're gonna
say stephen right
but then you get the hint you get the
ideas sometimes just saying that sucks
isn't helpful sometimes um just staring
off into space is super not helpful
but it all starts with that original
conversation so stephen again i love
your heart man i love that you're trying
to get this right and connect with
people
men and women you're not worth what's in
your head you're not worth strong arms
although both of those things help
sometimes there are times when my wife
says i just can't lift that dog food bag
john will you pick it up and i'll say
yeah that's right and i'll pick up the
dog food bag and i will literally feel
good about it that's embarrassing but i
will i'll
be like
and then that's kind of my utility for
the day other than this awesome hard to
grasp
hard to measure our culture gives two
craps about it and that's this thing
that is called presence i just am here
i'm with you i'm listening i'm looking
at you i want you to know that you're
known and that you have value just
because and i hope that by me doing this
you're reciprocating that and we're here
together
and now the tree is getting real deep
roots in that soil
and it's a beautiful awesome messy
messy thing